hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today are going to be
starting our coverage of the 2015 zurich
chess challenge one of the most
prestigious events all year this
tournament actually last year had the
highest average rating of any chess
tournament in the history of the world
that was an average rating of 2801 this
year we have five top-10 players and the
sixth player is in the top 12 so we have
the second-place player in the world
fabiano caruana playing some of the best
chess in the world right now and the
sixth rating we have vision on so he
actually just lost to potentially win
the World Chess Championship to Magnus
Carlsen eighth we have vladimir kramnik
ninth levon aronian tenth nakamura and
twelfth we have Sergey Hardy Atkins as
you can see this field is stacked
there's not too many people they only
really invite the best of the best so
excited to have this tournament over the
next week or so so we're going to go and
get started today with an exciting match
between Caruana the second rated player
in the world in my opinion you know one
of the best next to magnus carlsen in
one of the youngest that has a potential
to actually overtake magnus carlsen in
the years to come so he's always
exciting to watch from Italy so Caruana
is going to be taken on Nakamura
Nakamura from the United States going to
be playing the black pieces so
definitely going to have a challenge in
front of him playing against such a
strong young player with the white
pieces so without further ado we'll go
ahead and get into it Caruana starts
with pawn to e4 aggressive opening nice
from him nakamura pawn to c5 the
Sicilian defense Knight f3 upon these
six again this is the the Sicilian
offense Knight takes here on d4 Knight
f6 Knight c3 and then that Kimura has a
lot of different options to choose from
he decides to go for the night or if
defense which is if you kind of look at
it kind of looks like a strange opening
but actually does a lot accomplished is
quite a bit in the Sicilian defense it
really locks down the square here on b5
which is a key square for whites white
really wants to kind of control this so
pawn to a6 is somewhat of a just setting
up a good position for black that he can
maybe later on extend on the Queen said
if he wants to pawn here to B's five he
can always get his Queen in vault into
the game so very very nice move from
Nakamura now caruana decided to go
forward an interest
move here and he played pawn to h3
something that I don't see very often
it's kind of gone out of favor in the
past few years way more common would be
Bishop to g5 and then followed by pawn
to f4 again very aggressive taking a
very aggressive line on the kingside
other moves that I see a lot in the
night off defense is the Bishop to e3
but decided to go for something a little
bit different so pawn to h3 you could
definitely tell that he prepared
specifically for this tournament against
the night Dorf defense because we see
some interesting moves from him pawn to
e5 this does allow Caruana to later on
attack this backward pawns here on d6 or
something that Nakamura is going to be
thinking about in the back of his own
and then night back here to e2 and this
is kind of what I was talking about as
far as this is a you can tell the he
prepared for this line because knight to
e 2 is not a move you see very often it
blocks to the development of the bishop
which are the bishop here on f1 also
blocks the development of this Queen
here on do you want if it kind of wants
to go to an ad I diagonal night here to
be three very common even just coming
back here Knight to f3 still controlling
the center of the board opening up the
center for the Queen to get involved
this light squared Bishop very very
powerful but Caruana being a strong
player prepared for this and said night
to e2 was the move that he wanted to go
with upon to h5 so nakamura deciding to
be a little bit aggressive on the
kingside wanted to kind of lock down the
square here on g4 it does potentially
make any castling a little awkward for
him usually not in the Sicilian defense
going to see castling on the queenside
two videos decided to cast on the King
side is going to have to make sure that
he doesn't have to worry about all this
pressure because his pawns have extended
a little bit further than you typically
want to have when you castle on one side
of the board Caruana continues with pond
g3 Knight to d7 getting this night more
involved into the game a bishop here to
g5 and then bishop here to e7 so knock
mores opening up the door if he wants to
go ahead and decide to castle on the
kingside both sides again don't have the
most protection as they typically would
want if you feel keto your bishop here
to g2 typically your pawns going to
on h2 so both sides may decide to castle
but definitely not going to be as strong
as defense that they're definitely gonna
have to keep an eye on that not the more
could decide to go ahead and keep this
King in the middle but it probably going
to be a little bit safer just to castle
on the kingside not having to worry too
much since only one pond is kind of
extended here on h5 we now see pond
pushing forward to a for basically
counter-attacking this square here on b5
always really wanted to control it his
bishop can come out here is night here
to be five so it isn't one black they
just control this the entire game
especially if black wants to push
forward with pawn here to be five so
just trying to take sum of the squares
away that black might want to go to now
we see the night coming here to see five
just centralizing it attacking some of
the central squares here on e4 also
attacking this pawn here on a4a bishop
here to g2 just going to try to control
this long diagonal as long as possible
bishop here to e-cigs both sides just
getting all their minor pieces involved
into the game is as fast as possible
upon here to a five you know fabiano had
a few different options you could have
play i really like the pawn to b4
forcing the night to come back here and
then plague pond to a5 definitely
extends the pawn structure a little bit
further on the queenside but i think
this is definitely playable decided to
play a little bit differently and played
pawn up here to a five and then after
the pond comes down here to be five he
plays on Posada and actually captures
here on b6 this yes this is a legal move
I know for some of maybe the newer
players this looks weird but if your
opponent plays up this pawn two squares
you have one move than one move only to
capture like this it does look a little
funny but after the queen plays white
now plays pawn here to be here and this
is kind of what he was going for that's
why he didn't play the pawn here to be
four although I still think he could
have this basically allows him to
control the square here on a four and
also a somewhat central square here on
c4 now knock and more decides to go and
cast on the kingside caruana falls right
behind with castling on the King side as
well and then pushing forward with pawn
to a5 queen up here to d2 just want to
make sure you get it involved into the
action it's not it's still controlling
the suit in the board but now it allow
to kind of control this night here on c3
and also controlling this Bishop here on
g5 Rooke over here to c 8 so you can see
a lot of pressure being put on nakamura
on the queenside rook over here to d1
and then pawn to a for this is an
interesting move in the game it it's
pretty much equal on both sides now
caruana may have a slight advantage
because he went first and so he still
has maybe a slight tempo advantage but
nakamura plays an interesting move pawn
hits at 84 and I think this is a great
move because it really takes a high
level thinking player that it's kind of
at the top of his game to give up
material for a setup that he likes a
little bit better so after the pond
takes here on a 4 he now plays Bishop
here to see for recognizing that hey he
just didn't want to have to worry about
this pawn here on b3 it was really
really holding down the square here on
c4 that's where he wanted his bishop and
he's okay giving up material if his
pieces can be in a better position but
it's very very hard to find definitely
very hard to play that move especially
in the first game against such a
talented players probably our kawana so
it's it's not clear right now how
Nakamura is actually going to take this
advantage or take this sacrifice that he
gave up and turn it into an advantage
Caruana definitely right now still has
the material advantage so both sides you
know have something they're playing for
Nakamura is going to try to control the
center of the board especially now that
he has the bishop here on c4 car horn is
going to try to hold on to his material
advantage and then try to just exchange
pieces off as much as possible get
towards the endgame being up upon and
then potentially see if you can actually
win the game Oh or have a pretty easy
draw we now see pawn to a five and then
the Queen comes back here to a d8 this
is probably a lot better than you know
rook taking here on a five and then
bishop taking on f6 we see the rook come
down we see an exchange on each seven
we're taking over here than the Queen
taking probably not nearly as good for
black so just decides to go ahead and
play his Queen back here to d8 which is
completely fine now the bishop comes off
the board again we kind of talked about
what both sides are going to be looking
to do here so Bishop to f6 the Queen up
here taking this backward pawn here on
d6 which usually has a hard time having
someone defending it so he wants to go
ahead and exchange off Queens if
possible nakamura decides to go ahead
and take doesn't want to have to deal
with anything crazy you know you could
see a roof taking here on a five and
then the Queen takes the bishop takes
now the root comes up here on d 8 and
then all of a sudden black is down in
material that's going to be bad so it's
very important that Nakamura exchanges
correctly and that's what knocker
fabiano caruana wants him to do right
now he wants to go and exchange off that
Queen on the board he's again up in
material right now that appear to be
seven attacking the rook the rooks just
going to come back here to d2 now this
rook comes down here to a5 taking that
material Caruana still up a material by
one pond but Nakamura has the aggression
right now his rooks are very active this
Bishop here on c4 is doing a whole lots
of both of these bishops here on f6 and
g2 aren't doing too much but we do see
Nakamura with the bishop the double
bishop pair which in an open game which
this is since the pawns aren't kind of
controlling the entire board a lot of
times are very difficult for you know
players to play against because double
Bishop pairs can just control so much of
the board we now see look over here to a
b-1 attacking the knight Knight coming
down here to see 5 centralizing might
appear to d5 really great square for
this night it's a great outpost he does
have the pawn here on e4 it'd be great
as well for knock more if he had a piece
you know let's say a minor piece here on
d4 so great central square for the snack
going to be very difficult for nakamura
to do much unless he wants to go ahead
and exchange what you pie doesn't want
to exchange even more material if he
doesn't have to definitely doesn't want
to give up his double bishop pair if he
doesn't have to Bishop coming back here
to a d8 pawn appear to age for trying to
give a little bit of room here on the
kingside rope down here to a three-night
here to see three protecting this night
as well rook over here to a eight so
nakamura splain is simple he wants to
try to get all of his pieces over here
on the queenside and start to attack
caruana still wants to just exchange off
as
much material as possible just doesn't
want to have to worry about any of the
attacking over here on the queenside
route down here to d1 Bishop here to a5
trying to get into the action now the
Knights going to come up here to be five
wants to start to going on to the attack
root down here to a to any time you can
get your rook to the seventh rank if
you're white or on the second rank if
you're black that's going to be good
very difficult for your opponent to
really deal with but we do see the
bishop come up here to f3 and then upon
here to g6 just solidifying this pawn
chain right here on that appear to seven
forcing the King to move now the night
comes back here to see six probably
don't want to do anything too crazy
right now you don't have to really try
to take material right now if you're
probably arc wanna caruana just make
sure you don't make any mistakes on
board not over here to a for that appear
to a d6 probably better than taking here
on e5 then you can see the bishop take
here on b5 rook taking on b5 than the
night down here to see three probably
just way too much trouble for fabiano to
deal with so instead decides to just go
ahead and play night here to d6 not
under a ton of pressure right now Bishop
coming back here to e6 and then rook up
here to be seven so nakamura first
brought his rook down here to a2 and now
fabi our fabiano caruana has done the
same he brings his rook up here to the
seventh-ranked exactly where you want to
do it putting a lot of pressure on his
opponent t dau has his knights and his
rook attacking the square here on f7 so
white starting to put a lot of pressure
on black black has to find something to
do because you can tell he's down in
material and he has yet to find a way to
kind of use that sacrifice and actually
turn it into any sort of advantage we
now see the rook taking here on c2
attacking this night and that's going to
get out come to e5 taking that material
right there night over here to see Five
now the risk and swing over here to e7
attacking this Bishop right here King up
here to f8 so Caruana is trying to be
pretty aggressive 9 up here to see 6
trying to get his minor pieces a little
more in the center of the board a little
higher though now we see night too
you a be three Pawn pushing forward to
e5 solidifying this outpost here on d6
and then Bishop here to be 6 very very
telling move Nakamura he wants to attack
this square here on f 2 and white has to
deal with it right away he has the rook
here on t2 he really wants to come down
take it with his Bishop and then he can
have a discovered attack unfortunately
for caruana he plays a fatal mistake
something you typically don't see from
him but he plays rook over here to be 7
and that does not stop this bishop at
all coming down here to f2 which is what
nakamura plays without much hesitation
now the King moves to a g2 the bishop is
going to come back here to see 5a
discovered attack with the rook here on
c2 and after the King comes back here
the works going to swing down to a two
and Caruana decides to go ahead and
resign in this position there's just
nothing that he can really do with both
of these rooks and this Bishop here on
c5 controlling this long diagonal
there's no real way for white to kind of
hold on to here sometimes the viewers
will ask well you know how's how's this
even a lost a game so if you kind of run
it through a computer and kind of look
at that the best moves possible all
white can really hope for is to kind of
stop the threat right here so Bishop
here to g2 the night coming down here to
d4 stopping the bishop right here Roke
over here to h1 now we can just see the
bishop take if the rook takes here all
of a sudden the night could just take
that I can check if you wants to to try
to slow it down a little bit but all
that's going to do is delay the
inevitable after the King moves a little
bit you can get the night involved into
the game and it's going to be checkmate
for naaka more so a really great game I
think it didn't go all the way fabiano
resigned well before then but a really
really great game from nakamura played
well the entire game even giving
sacrifices up in material because he
trusted his position and his pieces and
he knew what to do with him so a really
excited that we had such an exciting
game coming out of round one especially
at these high levels sometimes it's
almost expected that you're going to see
just tons of drawls but a little
disappointed in Caruana one of my
favorite players to see him actually
lose this game after playing well with a
line that we don't see very often maybe
starting some theory in the h3 move in
the night door if the defense from white
kind of disappointed it to see him
falter at the end but congrats to the
american nakamura first game he's in the
lead right now so we're going to be
having continued coverage for throughout
the entire tournament so definitely
check back but hopefully you guys and
watch enjoyed watching this video learn
something i'll see you guys the next one
thanks for watching